[Music]
but it would be this right from being a
stuck in a house for three months in Big
Brother you're locked inside of hell
so that sucks - traveling the world
together in just one straight from Big
Brother to the Amazing Race
this was our Redemption it was always on
our shoulders you know good or bad you
know failure whatever it's it's all in
your shoulders so first five months of
Jessica Graff and Cody Nixon's
relationship all played out in front of
reality TV cameras now that you've had a
little bit of time away from reality TV
cameras to really figure out this
relationship in the real world
what's that way in Cody tele T they
haven't spent more than a few hours
apart since reuniting at the Big Brother
finale back in September do you want to
be engaged soon I mean of course I do
that's not a question you know that for
now the pair is just enjoying life away
from the cameras splitting time between
Cody's place in Texas and Jess's in
California they say they eventually want
to start a family in the Lone Star State
a big family how many kids do you want
but chances are we won't get a Jody
reality show Cody says he's probably
done with reality TV after The Amazing
Race not going back and doing big
weather all stars if they asked you I
wouldn't still their reality TV
experience wasn't all bad
they walked away with each other and a
couple of lifelong friends who do you
still talk to from Big Brother period
yeah one of my biggest pet peeve is pet
peeves is hearing people say you know it
was just a game if someone treats me
negatively outside of Big Brother for
three months I'm not going to continue
your relationship for them is there
anybody that you never want to see you
get from anybody else anybody else right
even I know actually I love Ramsay's I
still feel bad for you
I mean for her to go yeah yeah that
attachment to you
sorry Joey again it's a game
you